welcome back to las vegas now women in
construction week was last month
and today we're looking at some
inspiring young ladies who are looking
into entering the field thanks to the
lurie shock foundation take a look
resharp pier foundation is a foundation
recreations with the
vision and the mission in mind to create
opportunities such as hands-on and
vocational
training for kids before they graduate
in high school
and we decided to start that opportunity
in construction
our charter school just opened this
august
and it's for sixth and seventh grade
girls this year next year we'll roll up
to eighth grade
it is to empower our young women
allow our children to dream to believe
in themselves
get a good education become leaders and
find their voice
so today we're actually out here thanks
to rose constructors
for offering the time and the job site
here at
elementary that's under construction
right now by roach constructors
they're really going to go through and
walk through this building and show the
girls
how construction happens from heavy
equipment
to the framers to high equipment that we
have here sizzy lip boom list
and really introduce them what really a
construction site looks like
the elevator company will not deliver on
rough dirt
that sensitive equipment that they're
delivering so
we prepare the area to receive the
equipment we were very fortunate to hook
up with the rye ship foundation
introducing our young women
into other possible careers in the
construction field which is
predominantly a male dominated
i think it's so important to get women
involved in construction and i've been
very actively involved for more than 25
years and
involved in organizations like the
associated builders and contractors and
other women in construction
organizations and
it's key in any area any field for women
to get involved and there's so many
different opportunities for them
you guys can see how they're doing their
job how they're going down
sanding the walls they use stilts rather
than a ladder
or a rolling scaffold it's much quicker
than having to move your scaffold
this experience was pretty fun for me
because i got to learn how
things work in construction the
construction of the school was
approximately
31 million 100 000 i know
about how much money it costs to build
construction
like the workers here and have really a
big diversity of like
these people creating and doing amazing
things i've never thought about
construction i really just wanted to be
a
ob gyn instead and i feel like
maybe i will be in construction because
i do have an
artsy side what this program means to me
and what i think it means to all the
girls is
that it's been an opportunity for them
to learn about
what goes into a building from the very
first
design and drawing to all the materials
and then the field trip here has been
amazing because they've been able to
learn what's going on on an actual
construction project
for donations or sponsorship
opportunities visit
lurieshockfoundation.org
las vegas now we'll be right back